this like conversation just reminded me
that i like i went through like a phase
like you know every you're a kid and
sometimes you go through phases right so
i remember the first time i've ever saw
david blaine on on tv doing stream
matching and i'm just like i want to do
that yeah that looks incredible and i
remember like going through this phase
where
i you know there was these packages this
was before you could just
google or youtube how to do magic tricks
online so i actually had to like pay
like send off i had to convince my
parents to be send off money to this
company that like supposedly sent you
magic tricks and uh and like magic magic
secrets and all that sounds like a scam
i'm surprised like for the one time in
my life it wasn't a scam wow they
actually like sent me back like a vhs
though [ __ ] like played and i remember
you like learning how to do like a bunch
of these magic tricks yeah i was like
great i'm gonna impress everyone around
me but like you there's never a moment
where you go to a party or you go to a
family gathering yeah and like you don't
want to be that guy who just brings out
a deck of cards
yeah it's just like oh like you know i i
know magic i have i have a deck of
even though i learned how to use these
skills as a kid i never i never was able
to show them off so it's i mean it's
kind of like martial arts in somewhere
right
because uh you know talking to
i remember seeing this youtube video
about like why do people learn martial
arts because you basically
you basically spend years of your life
you spend years and years honing this
one skill for like these moments that
will only last maybe like a few minutes
of your life right unless you unless you
go to tournaments and stuff like that
right because like you like you're
you're training yourself for like that
one fight you're gonna be in in like
whatever moment that's going to be right
yeah but then you spend years building
up to that moment and like what if what
if you just [ __ ] up in that moment right
what if what if all the training just
for just leaves your body in that one
moment what's the dude's like nine foot
yeah yeah yeah right i didn't drive this
i'm like [ __ ] dude
wait are you getting it are you oh [ __ ]
that's my weight class sorry yeah
i i i feel like that's the good thing
though about like doing youtube is that
like for me i just use videos to do [ __ ]
that i otherwise wouldn't normally do so
like with like martial arts for instance
like i i remember oh my god i don't even
remember how many years ago this was
this is like a four or five year old
video i uh i learned how to like
backflip
you know i was going to say if there's
one skill i want to learn how to do
actually it's the back flip well i just
like standing yes
you're just standing back i did a
standing back flip once in a video it
was like
it was me and like was your power to
encourage you they're trying to get rid
of you it was like no no it was i was in
japan already i was in japan and it was
me dogan and uh my friend you were above
the age of like 15 doing this yeah this
was like four years ago oh my god that's
like suicide yeah and we yeah because we
cosplayed as narrator characters
that's the reason you learn how to
backflip because of naruto because it
was a narrative online sponsorship oh my
and i was like i was like well i need to
do something naruto related you know
what i'll learn ninja tricks and my
ninja tricks i mean just tricking and
learning how to backflip so how long did
it take you to learn how to backflip uh
like
like i think we were in that gym for
maybe like five six hours
but i learned how to do like other
tricking like tricks because like dogan
used to be like a [ __ ] like
professional trick trickster is that the
right word
sounds like a persona character
yeah yeah he used to do like tricking
and then he like hurt his uh knees i
think really badly and he like couldn't
stop doing it but he was like he taught
me how to like backflip and [ __ ] and uh
i did it successfully once and i haven't
done it since could you do you think
you'd be able to relearn and uh pull off
another backflip maybe because i think
what took me so long and i think what
the the level of entry is is that you
just have to get over your fear yeah
yeah yeah that's what like because i've
seen people trying to learn backflips
yeah i'm just like that looks really
that looks like a really interesting
because i snapped your neck just get
over yeah get over the fear
yeah because like it's not natural for
you to be like all right jump and also
pull your entire body back like this
yeah at the same time like your body's
just like no
i think that's cool but the one skill i
learned i also love this channel it's uh
mike boyd a boy yeah he does the he just
like
how long can it take me to learn next
thing oh i think i know that character
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think he's one
video and i really want to learn how to
do this it's he has an umbrella and he's
holding the umbrella and
he this the trick is is that he throws
the umbrella in front of him it goes
like quite quite far away and then it
opens in mid-air and while he's walking
he catches the umbrella as it as he's
like so it fully opens yeah yeah yeah
floats down he catches it yeah and i
want to learn how to do that there's so
many like little tricks like that i want
to learn how to imagine you're on like
the japanese street and just like
right it's like some anime [ __ ] i want
to do that with like a cap where like
you throw the cap and it lands perfectly
on your head but that's not good enough
because you always need to like pull it
down right yeah
it's like immediate you're like walking
you're good to go no no readjustment
you've got the umbrella oh no you know
what's a truly useless skill i've always
wanted to learn is to draw a perfect
hand so oh yeah i've seen that yet but
i've seen so many videos and every time
i see it i'm just like not that is the
most satisfying thing in the world just
like freehand
yeah
yeah the guy the guy
that is a cool party trick everyone has
a pencil not everyone has a rubik's cube
exactly exactly i don't carry a pencil
on me all the time well no if you're in
someone's house oh yeah yeah actually
you're not going to be in a house that
doesn't have a drawing equipment
of some kind have you ever been in a
house where they just don't have any
pens and pencils
i think it's my house already yeah
that's that's just connor's house right
that's my house
true millennial right here
what's what's penciled
actually i don't think i have a pencil
in my house
i have pens no there's no way you guys
live in japan there's more paperwork
than [ __ ] anything yeah
you just use pads well yeah that's what
i mean like drawing things yeah i guess
like now that i'm thinking
i don't draw
anything
when was the last time i drawed
something actually like the sad music
player i haven't drawn anything i
haven't seen the accident
i haven't drawn anything i just i just
have like zero skill in drawing and i
have done for my entire life i think i
don't know something we need to do like
a drawing competition now but you said
that somebody who also sticks with
drawing i believe it's like it's like
singing it's like i don't think you're
just like naturally good like
immediately or maybe you are actually i
think some people are some people but i
think you you do have to practice though
yeah of course you have to practice but
i remember i think the last time i drew
something i can't remember what the uh
context was but i think i had to draw a
cat for something
oh it was the netflix shoot i remember
because it was for anime club in netflix
and i had to draw a cat on the
whiteboard or something and then joey
just said joey just smell like joey i
was drawing this cat and joey could not
recognize like that it was even an
animal that i was drawing you know what
this what can you draw like a uma i i
don't know what it was like it was like
it was not of this earth
like those uh like unidentified what is
it
like like the chupacabra
like that level it's like urban legend
[ __ ]
super camera what the [ __ ] the uma
this is the first time i've ever
unidentified mysterious animals yeah
like like ufo this is the first [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard you know like
mothman or like chupacabra like any of
those
although when i was 10 i did believe
chupacabra but but
why why would you believe in supercars
because you're 10 years old you believe
in you believe harry potter is real when
you're 10 years old like mexican or
something yeah it was mexican or spanish
i mean
means
means goat drinker or something what is
the chupacabra
you [ __ ]
it was this like viral video in like
early 2000s i think where like there was
just it was mexico or spain or somewhere
some spanish-speaking country where like
just some dudes went into a forest at
night because they heard some [ __ ] and
then there was this like
creature
that appeared on camera it was like a
goat person right yeah it was like it
was like eating a goat or it looked like
a demonic goat yeah and like i remember
like back then like it was a huge
sensation especially in japan it was a
massive sensation because four and early
2000s uh video it was like way too high
quality like it looked way too real like
you look you look at the l you look at
the chupacabra videos now and you're
like oh that could almost like if you
weren't aware of it that could almost
come off as convincing yeah because it
was like too good and then people were
like shocked when they found out it was
fake and it's like oh who would have
thought there isn't a [ __ ] goat
drinker demon thing in the forests of
mexico whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah i
think like the only thing that i
believed as a kid or i wanted to believe
i really wanted to believe like the loch
ness monster oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
because a kid you're just obsessed with
dinosaurs and you're like exactly and
stories yeah yeah like uh thinking cool
[ __ ] yeah exists out there but it
doesn't it's like everyone you know
everyone wanted to believe moby dick was
a real like bigfoot like a lot of big
food a lot of people really [ __ ]
image
like doing this people really believe
bigfoot for some reason but like it it
also like makes you think what if what
if one of those things was real right
what would what would make you actually
believe it right because seeing it if i
yeah if i see it like
yeah if i see like a news article of
like scientists like properties
incredible be like yeah this is okay
because because like i remember because
i think we have talked about this before
but like i mean it's been proven by the
government that ufos exist and like
nobody freaked out over it nobody really
reacted to alex jones
if it was
if i said to you oh by the way we found
an alien spaceship we know it's an alien
by the way you'd be freaking out but i
feel like oh we have no [ __ ] clue
what that thing was yeah it could have
been it could have been like a drone
or something
everyone like doesn't because you're
like oh well i'm sure there's an
explanation for it we just don't know
but if it's like by the way we literally
found the things from men in black and i
think everyone's gonna be like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean like because
i mean
it's weird right because you do look at
the videos i i do look at the videos of
the the ufo images and the ufo videos
and i'm just like that's freaky
and i do think ufos exist but do i think
it's aliens i don't know i don't i don't
know myself i don't know how to react to
it i guess
no i was gonna say like there was a
there was a weird part of me that saw
those like government file you know
videos which are like you know legit and
right because like why would why would
an organization like that lie yeah but
it's like i saw and i was like why does
that look like just every other ufo
video i've ever seen i think that's the
problem with it right because there's so
many fakes nowadays that even when the
real thing is actually released you're
so desensitized with it you're just like
it's like the fake ones looked more real
yeah yeah right right
it's just it i thought seeing ufos
real ufos would be more impressive and i
don't know why i thought that but i just
thought it would be more impressive and
it just wasn't you know i i mean i
assume that if uh an alien species finds
us uh we will probably be dead
wow they just wipe us out oh there's
like
think of it if an alien spaceship if
alien civilization had the opportunity
to or had the capability of finding
other planets and going around scouting
yeah they're more technologically
advanced than us yeah we're pretty
[ __ ] yeah odds are they're not going
to want to be like hey friends they're
going to be like let's take all your
stuff yeah
you have minerals we need collect the
minerals
yeah
like [ __ ] starcraft
why would they give a [ __ ] they're not
going to give a [ __ ] they'll treat us
like cows yeah i mean it's like it's
kind of i agree with you because i think
what if humanity had this had this we
would have
everything yeah we would we would [ __ ]
everyone yeah we
[ __ ] ourselves over enough like let
alone another speech we can't even save
our own [ __ ] planet let alone some
other species planet you know anyone who
thinks that like we wouldn't just blow
off a planet if they if we just thought
they were a little strange-looking yeah
yeah that doesn't have enough
especially if they have like natural
resources or something
a lot of people would be like i don't
think we should do this but the
government of whatever the united
government of all whatever would be like
bye-bye bye-bye planet yeah
oh let's find another one but they are
rich in iron we must destroy